last
happy
um
foreign
what's going on
um
okay
is
him
oh here's my money
with
um
[Music]
that was yours
uh
two minute warning on the press briefing
two minute awarding for the press
briefing thank you
um
okay
really
[Laughter]
good morning
good to see you
yeah but that's right
anything else
hi everyone
okay i have a couple of items of good
news for the american people today to
kick us off
uh today the president will sign an
extension of the paycheck
protection program which passed both the
house and senate
with wide bipartisan majorities since
the beginning of the pandemic 400
000 small businesses have closed for
good and millions more are struggling to
stay open
in december congress provided an
additional 284 billion for the paycheck
protection program
in just two months we've approved over
200 billion dollars
worth of forgivable loans to more than
three million small
businesses and in this round we've
distributed a greater share of relief to
very
small businesses so today the president
will sign
the extension act into law we want small
businesses to know that help is here
and they now have until may 31st to
apply
uh as we do every week um jeff uh hosted
a call
with governors uh from across the
country uh he
of course uh provided them an update on
what the president announced yesterday
uh that by april 19th
90 of adults in the us will be eligible
for vaccination
90 will have a vaccination site within
five miles
of where they will live uh this will be
made possible by increasing the federal
retail pharmacy program from 17 000 to
nearly 40
000 stores nationwide a program that
started out as a pilot and has been very
successful he also announced there'll be
an increase
of supply to over 33 million vaccine
doses across
all of our channels which is going to
help meet the needs
with the moving forward of the
eligibility timeline
another update um in terms of our
getting the checks out to people
uh there have been uh there are a
significant number of social security
recipients who do not file
taxes as we noted earlier or a couple
weeks ago i should say uh direct
payments when out
very quickly to those who file taxes
every year who do it via direct deposit
and thanks the collaboration between the
irs and the social security
administration
uh they will soon announce that we are
on track to send those payments uh out
this weekend the majority of people
should see them in the bank account in
their bank account on wednesday
april 7th which is obviously a very
positive step forward
finally as many of you saw earlier this
morning the president announced his
historic slate of judicial
nominees of his administration the first
historic slate i should say
with 11 candidates overall this is an
unprecedented
fast start for any president in the u.s
history on judicial nominations
this is also a groundbreaking slate in
many ways
it includes four nominees who served as
public defenders
four who are members of the aapi
community and nominee who if confirmed
would be the first muslim american
federal judge
in history none of the l11 nominees
are women and overall this group
represents a paradigm shift in the type
of people who can see themselves on the
federal bench while still
maintaining the president's absolute
highest standards
for the qualifications integrity and
fairness of each individual being
considered
so lots of news go ahead kick us off
thank you jen
i want to start by asking on guns
it is noted actually 40 years ago today
with the attempted assassination
of president reagan but some gun safety
groups have expressed disappointment of
the president's
sidestep of the issue in his news
conference last week can you give an
update on what is in the works in terms
of a timetable for possible executive
actions on funds
well first let me say the president
understands their frustration
uh he is somebody who has fought for gun
safety measures
since he was in the senate himself he
did that in his effort to fight for the
brady bill
in his effort to fight for a ban on
assault weapons and in his leadership
getting putting in place almost two
dozen executive actions
on gun safety when he was in the biden
obama biden
administration right now we're working
on a couple of levers
uh one is working with congress there
are two background check bills that have
moved their way through the house
uh many of you may have seen this
weekend senator chris murphy clearly a
leader on these issues somebody who has
been a leader since
a newtown and even before has seized a
path forward
we've seen an openness by even some
republicans to having a debate and
discussion
we'll take that while that is moving
while there are discussions on that
front
and the president will certainly be
engaged in those we are also continuing
to review
and consider what the options are for
executive actions
uh we hope to have an update on that
soon i don't have an exact day for you
at this point in time okay uh follow up
on that and then one other matter
on guns does the president still plan to
go to colorado after that shootings
there and if so when
i don't have an update on a trip to
colorado obviously that trip would be
done in coordination
uh with the leaders in the state
community that was impacted
by this terrible tragedy but i don't
have any plans to preview for a trip to
colorado at this point and then one more
thing on another
lighter matter uh it's obviously a
presidential tradition throughout the
first pitch on opening day
which i'm happy to report is thursday uh
but the nationals have said that the
president declined their invitation to
go to
this year why is that why is he not
going is this about crowds in the park
he's not sending wrong messaging
why is he choosing not to be there on
thursday well first let me say i know
the president's eager to get out to
national stadium
many beautiful days many beautiful
baseball games ahead this spring it's
not on his schedule
uh this week but i certainly expect that
baseball
fans will be hearing from him uh in
in the next couple days go ahead thanks
jen
uh question about your infrastructure
proposal being released tomorrow
is it going to focus more on
shovel-ready projects that could get
underway right away
or is it focused more on projects that
might take a couple of years to get
started
but could ultimately have a bigger
impact it's a great question and i
expect we'll have more to outline on
how quickly things can happen once he
delivers the speech tomorrow
but let me just say that the speech
tomorrow is about
making an investment in america not just
modernizing our roads or railways or
bridges but
building an infrastructure of the future
so some of it is certainly
infrastructure shovel-ready projects
some of it is
how do we expand broadband access some
of it is ensuring that we are
addressing uh the needs in people's
homes and communities
so there are a range of components that
will be
he'll talk about when he proposes his
pat his uh
his ideas tomorrow uh when he lays that
out in his speech in pittsburgh
and how much more should wealthy
americans expect to pay will the top
marginal rate go back
to 39.6 under this proposal
well i expect that um tomorrow again the
speech is really about his vision his
vision for creating jobs
good paying union jobs and really
investing in the industries of the
future but he thinks it's responsible
it's the responsible thing to do
to propose a way to pay for that over
time so
uh and he also believes that there's
more that can be done
to uh make the corporate tax code fair
uh and so i expect that will be the
focus of his uh remarks on the on taxes
tomorrow and what about the estate tax
is that something you're also
considering increasing again i'm not
gonna get too far ahead of the
president's own speech and proposal and
i know we'll
be previewing it more in the next 24
hours but he believes that there's more
that can be done to make
the corporate tax code fair to reward
work not wealth
to ensure that we can invest in the
future industries that are going to help
all people in this country and one other
topic 23 countries have signed on to
the idea of this who treaty that would
improve
information sharing during future
pandemics why
hasn't the u.s signed on well
we believe it's vital um in
working uh with international partners
in other countries and of course
strengthening and reforming
our international efforts as it relates
to addressing pandemics and future
pandemics
we do have some concerns primarily about
the timing and launching into
negotiations
for a new treaty right now and we
believe that could divert attention
away from substantive issues regarding
the response
preparedness for future pandemic threats
and we believe that should be our focus
currently
but we're certainly open to look and
looking for a continued
collaboration with the global community
go ahead
does president biden believe that the
millions of americans who lost
loved ones to coba 19 deserve a better
response than one that they've gotten
from the who
in terms of looking into origins for
covet 19.
well i think he believes that the
american people the global community
uh the medical experts the doctors all
of the people who've been working to
save lives
the families have lost loved ones all
deserve greater transparency they
deserve better information
uh they deserve uh steps that are taken
by the global community to provide that
so there was an extensive statement put
out um
by a number of countries including the
us but let me highlight
when we're still reviewing uh the report
but let me highlight some of the
concerns that have
come up to date the report lacks crucial
data
information and access it represents a
partial and
incomplete picture there was a joint
statement as i noted that was put out we
also welcome a similar statement from
the eu and eu members
sending a clear message the global
community shares these concerns
there are steps from here that we
believe should be taken there's a second
stage in this process
that we believe should be led by
international international and
independent
experts they should have unfettered
access to data
they should be able to ask questions of
people who are on the ground
at this point in time and that's a step
the who could take and that statement
says
that the u.s joins these countries and
expressing shared
concerns but the statement quite frankly
is pretty
bureaucratic and um perhaps does not
meet the moment
of the seriousness of the crisis here in
this country in terms of the death toll
so what is the white house's actual
reaction to
this report from the who was it simply
inadequate
well the report uh is still being
reviewed
by our team of experts 17 experts are
reviewing it
and it's not sufficient we agree and we
have long said as i just stated it lacks
crucial data
information it lacks access it lacks
transparency
it certainly we don't believe that in
our review to date that
it meets the moment it meets the impact
that this pandemic has had on the global
community and that's why
we also have called for additional
forward-looking steps and i will tell
you that negotiating between 20
countries or so to get a statement out
sometimes it appears bureaucratic but
well i can't speak on this
on the who report i expect we'll let our
view conclude and then we'll look for an
opportunity for him to speak to it but
i can uh certainly um confirm for you
that he shares these concerns
they are coming directly from him and
directly from our national security team
who has
looked at what uh the report has
presented to date uh they're still
reviewing and share the concerns issued
in that
statement uh that made those uh concerns
clear go ahead
thanks janet i just want to piggyback
off of that as well uh world health
organization director general
uh tedros one of his primary concerns
was that the
report may have glossed over if you will
uh the possibility that the the viruses
take from my lab
is that a central concern of the white
house as well and then when you when you
talk about cooperation
has has china not cooperated enough in
the white house's opinion
well they have not been transparent they
have not provided underlying data
that certainly doesn't qualify as as
cooperation
uh you know the analysis performed to
date from our experts uh
you know our their concern is that there
is an additional support for one
hypothesis
it doesn't lead us to any closer of an
understanding or greater knowledge than
we had six to nine months ago about the
origin
it also doesn't provide us guidelines or
uh or steps uh recommended steps on how
we should prevent this from happening in
the future and those are
imperative and so that centers on the
hypothesis that would involve the lab
again it doesn't it doesn't lead to uh
it doesn't it doesn't provide us greater
uh understanding of uh the origin
of the virus and the second question
just on the next legislative package um
has the president started to reach out
to to moderates to
uh centrist republicans as well and to
kind of move them to get ahead of
you know some of the the things that we
saw with the last person
um you know the president uh will be of
course directly engaged um
in um in this effort to move this
package forward
uh i will say that what he views his
role uh
is as is laying out what a vision is a
broad vision a bold vision
for how we can invest in america
american workers our communities
uh we're also though uh very open to
hearing ideas
and proposals from members of congress
democrats or republicans
we know that 80 percent or more of
people in this country
democrats and republicans support
investing in infrastructure and of
course they will of course they do we're
13th in the world
um as it relates to infrastructure we're
the
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world that doesn't make a lot of sense
to most people across the country
more than one-third of bridges in this
country need repair that's 231 000
that's a lot of bridges
uh one in five miles or 886 thousand
miles of our highways and major
roads are in poor conditions those
aren't issues where democrats just have
concerns republicans have concerns
independents people who don't see
themselves as political
and he believes that investing we can't
afford not to invest
in improving our infrastructure there
are questions about
people that may have different ideas
about how to pay for it we're open to
hearing them so
hopefully people will bring forward
ideas last question uh the skinny budget
is due out this week
what programs or agencies should we
expect to see at booths in funding
i know people love the term skinny
budget but is actually just a
discretionary uh
guide um so it should be out soon and
we'll wait for it to come out and then
i'm sure we'll have an update from our
uh budget our own b team thank you jen
uh could you provide a bit more insight
into why the white house has felt the
need over the last few days to really
clarify
the vice president's role at the border
was that something that she
uh requested a clarification on i
actually think that
members of the media deserve to have an
understanding of what her exact role was
and
the president when he was the vice
president played a very specific role
too where he
uh was running point on the northern
triangle he told the story at the press
conference last week about how the
president called him back from turkey i
think it was
and he wants the vice president to play
a similar similar role
and engaging with these countries
engaging with their leaders
figuring out how to invest best how to
work in partnership
how to prevent corruption from taking
over to
put in place steps that will make the
journey less desirable
that is certainly a big assignment and
one the president is confident the vice
president will take on
do the plan always for her to focus on
the
northern triangle countries the root
causes as opposed to the border or did
something change
that was always the plan and that was
the announcement
okay uh i'd like to find out what the
white house thinks about what's
happening
in san diego where some public school
teachers are providing
in-person instruction at the san diego
convention center
to migrant children before their own
public school students
and these kids of course about 130 000
of them have been
at home doing online learning for about
a year now so what does the white house
think about that well i know you guys
have done a fair amount of reporting on
this so maybe you'll have more details
uh as i understand it san diego public
schools are opening
in early april april 12th to hybrid line
okay and students will be back in the
classroom and as i understand it this is
related
part-time uh and certainly you know our
objective from the white house opening
up five days a week a majority of
schools across the country
and they're on spring break right now
and this is related to volunteering or
being paid i'm not even sure you'd have
to ask the local school district
during spring break for these migrant
kids
yes the san diego county supervisor jim
desmond he says you know
i think it's great that there's
in-person learning for unaccompanied
minors from central america but i wish
every child in san diego county was
allowed the same opportunity for
in-person teaching so i guess the the
question is you know
does the white house think that this
sends the right message to these
130 000 kids in san diego and their
parents who've been stuck at home for
the last year well
i'm just saying that context is
important and these kids are going back
to school
for hybrid learning we of course want
that to be five days a week and we're
confident we'll get there
early next month and i believe they're
also on spring break right now so these
teachers are
would be i'm not sure if it's volunteer
or paid you'd have to ask the local
school district
um while the kids are on spring break
which i think the context is pretty
important
okay one question sorry about states
you know the byte administration they
just announced its intention to retain
the national space council and this is
on top of the white house voicing its
support for the space force yes
artemis program i mean these are three
programs or policies that
president trump and the trump
administration put in place so would it
be fair to say that space is one of the
space policies one of the few areas
where president biden actually
agrees with his predecessor i think
that that sounds accurate to me uh look
i think the president believes that
um the national space council as as you
uh as you just conveyed or just asked
about
uh provides an opportunity to generate
national space policy strategies
synchronize on america's space
activities at a time of unprecedented
activity
it's also an opportunity um to gen
generated by america's own activities in
space so
uh it certainly is a program or a
council i should say he's excited to
keep in place and one i think it's fair
to say he agrees
with the past administration's
maintaining the program
go ahead the white house has been
talking about a lot of different
types of infrastructure over the last
few weeks leading up to the announcement
tomorrow can you give us a sense
of what the general breakdown is going
to be on you know clean energy and
climate type projects versus
roads and bridges i know we will have an
extensive fact sheet that will break
down everything for you it is
uh it is quite long uh and i i don't
want to get too far ahead of the
president but i will let me let me see
if i can give you a little bit more of a
of a
breakdown not in terms of the numbers
but
um so certainly investing in we've
talked about this a little bit
roads rails and bridges is part of it
the president believes that
we can do that in a way where we can
create uh good paying
clean energy jobs union jobs uh that's
part of his vision for
investing in industries of the future he
also believes there's more we can do on
broadband
and ensuring that the far too large
percentage of the american people who
don't have access
uh have access and we invest in that
there's a lot of ways to do that i will
say though and he's very open to the
ideas coming from congress on how to do
it and they may have different
perspectives on how to do it
the right way to invest uh and to do it
um but he sees um you know clean energy
and clean energy jobs is central to his
uh own vision and his own objectives
you'll certainly hear him talk about
that
tomorrow and uh this is uh but the
speech is really about
um it's about jobs it's about investing
in the industries of the future
uh and it's about uh rebuilding parts of
our communities that have
long been uh forgotten does the white
house have a response to this uh this
new chinese law finalized uh earlier
today that uh
essentially allows them to bet
parliamentary candidates in hong kong
for so-called
non-patriots to not be allowed to run
for office i know we have certainly
expressed concerns about the
undemocratic steps of the chinese
government in the past i'll have to
check with our national security team i
had not asked them about this specific
piece but we will get back to you
shortly after the briefing go ahead
chris um so chuck schumer is urging
people to write and email
the president at the white house in
hopes uh that he will cancel
up to fifty thousand dollars of student
loan debt why do you think that
schumer has such a fundamentally
different reading
of what the president can and should do
and if you could answer yes or no
is this has the president ruled out
taking unilateral action on this
uh no he has not i will say that
i do have some good student loan news
for you which you didn't even know you
were going to t up for me but
we will be expanding the pause on
student loan interest and collections to
the more than 1 million borrowers
who are in default on a loan that was
made by a private lender in the old bank
back based
loan program known as the federal family
education loan program
the staff particularly protects 800 000
borrowers who are at risk of having
their tax refunds seized that's actually
pretty significant
uh steps the president continues to call
on congress to cancel ten thousand
dollars in debt for student loan
borrowers
that's something congress uh could take
an action on and he'd be
happy to sign we're still taking a
closer look at our action our options
on student loans this includes examining
the authorities we have
the existing loan forgiveness programs
that are clearly not working as well as
they should
this includes borrower defense total and
permanent disability charges
there's a lot of steps we're looking at
and we'll continue to review those and
be in touch of course with later schumer
about
uh our process do you have a sense of
the timing on that how long
those reviews might take i don't have an
update on the
on the timing there's a legal and a
policy review
uh oh trevor do you have a question i
didn't mean to i
always have a question of course so uh
first just on the the
infrastructure questions that we were
talking about you said yesterday that
there would be a dollar for dollar
accounting
of how um the measures would be paid for
yep paper over time paper over time is
is the president
willing to sign a bill that does not pay
dollar per dollar for
all of the proposals that he has well
the president believes it's responsible
to propose a way
for paying overtime for uh his vision
for investing in infrastructure and
uh and our economy and american workers
uh
there will be a range of views uh
including how to pay for it people
will be for or against some people may
not want to pay for it um and he's open
to having those discussions so
but the the the focus of his speech of
his proposal
is on investing in america we're talking
about um
tax uh reform proposals that uh would
help uh pay for it over time
but the reason he is putting this fort
is because he thinks it's responsible
to put forth a plan to pay for it um as
a as a means of discussing that but it's
really about investing in workers
he is open to deficit financing in a
final package
again i think we haven't even proposed
the speech yet uh there'll be a range of
views on capitol hill as we all
certainly know
he's proposing a way to pay for his
proposals over time
we'll look forward to hearing from
members of congress on how they want to
approach it given their such strong
support for infrastructure investment
across the country okay and
just sean a quick one on foreign policy
um
uh iran has come out and basically
already rejected
a proposal that you haven't even put on
the table yet um
about relaxing some of the sanctions
against them
uh to get them to come to the table they
say all of the sanctions need to be
relaxed before they'll consider any
changes on uh enrichment uh
is there any point to putting a proposal
on the table
if it's if it's already going to be a
non-starter
well we remain committed to pursuing a
diplomatic process to determine a way
forward
sometimes that takes some time and we
certainly have found that in the past as
it relates to negotiations
uh with iran um we remain ready to
reengage in meaningful diplomacy to
achieve a mutual return to compliance
with the jcpoa
commitments uh and that offer to discuss
and engage is on the table
go ahead patient one quick follow-up on
space and then two uh sure
so vice president pence had a pretty
public facing role with national space
council
he was kind of involved in policy making
i know it's a new new thing here but
vice president paris has a similar
involvement with the space council
uh it's a great question i i know it's
the space council technically falls
under the vice president's team in
office
um i'd have to talk to her team about
her public-facing role and i'm happy to
do that
gotcha long ambassadors so there is yet
to be an employment from the u.s
ambassador to china there's been some
reporting that there's rumors that kind
of shocking of who that person might
need
any updates on the appointment time
timeline even a short list
for that posting i know i've seen a lot
of names reported out there
um some of which would be great choices
uh but i i don't have an update uh
on the timeline for announcing the
nomination of ambassadors for the summer
time anything
fraud certainly hope so uh but uh i
don't have an update on on when the
president will make any decisions
on supreme court so about a year ago i
would say president biden and canada
biden committed to
putting a black woman on the supreme
court of course today's
um appointments and news kind of
generate some buzz on who those folks
might be
is there any update anything you can
advance for us on uh vice
president biden's efforts to put a black
christmas in supreme court any kind of
shortlist situation
that would require there being an
opening on the supreme court of course
there is not an opening on the supreme
court look i think there
is an incredible group of nominees the
president announced today
you know as someone who served for 17
years on the senate judiciary
committee as chairman and ranking member
he has a long history on judicial
appointments this is a priority
for him but our focus is on getting the
senate to confirm
these group of nominees and to continue
to build a pipeline of
additional highly qualified uh nominees
who are going to reflect
the values the president has outlined
commitments on the table
of course to nominate an
african-american woman to the supreme
court yes absolutely
it certainly is uh go ahead
yes one more follow up on the who is the
president disappointed with the target
show
does he believe did not up to the task i
think what the statement makes clear
is that we remain that uh that was
issued by the state department today
is that we remain confident in the role
of the who we
look to be a contributing member of the
who uh we have some concerns as we as
i've expressed about
uh the analysis that's been done so far
about the report and we think
that steps can be taken moving forward
in the second stage of the review
uh to ameliorate some of those go ahead
uh thank you jen uh i wanted to ask a
few questions uh
first i want to follow up on something
president biden said wednesday when he
was tasking vice president harris with
managing
root causes the border crisis uh he said
uh that
in addition to doing that she has quote
about five other major things she's
handling
could you clarify what those are well
first uh some of it is
uh is we have not yet announced yet so i
won't get ahead of those
um vice president harris is playing an
imperative role
uh out there connecting with the
american people about the american
rescue plan she's been traveling across
the country she's done a number of trips
and taken steps she's going to be
involved in our effort to communicate
with the public about
uh covid and the importance of the
effectiveness and efficiency of the
vaccine
uh and we'll have more to say soon a
quick follow
on a question i asked last week about
the white house and the marijuana policy
uh policy that impacted some private
staffers
you indicated that things might be
different if marijuana was federally
usual
actually the democrats in the senate led
by majority leader chuck schumer
preparing the bill's federal prohibition
of marijuana
does president support that he spoke
about this on the campaign he believes
in decriminalizing the use of marijuana
but his position has not changed
then federal rescheduling and end of
federal prohibition
that's been his position nothing has
changed and uh
regarding uh the who former president
trump
accused the who being a puppet of china
does this report confirm that claim
well i think we've expressed our
concerns about uh the role
the lack of transparency the lack of
data that has been provided broadly to
the global community
we believe there are steps that can be
taken moving forward to
ensure that an independent investigation
that global experts are involved in the
next stage of this process
but we also believe that the who is a
body that the united states
should be a part of that in order to
make changes happen we need to have a
seat at the table
and that's why we rejoined the who go in
the back thank you very much
jen uh i have one question now asia and
one question of asian americans
we know that japanese prime minister is
coming to visit and also both
nsc and state department are set to
host the their japanese and south korean
counterparts
as the representative of the foreign
press group i got a question from
the gk but the japanese media asked
your administration has focused on
working closely with
east asian allies like japan and south
korea to counter china but
these countries have a different
relationship with
china than the u.s has with china
so how will you have your asian allies
cooperate with you when they sit
on different interests than the us
i'm not sure i completely understand
your question are you asking if we
how will we discuss china and our
relationship with china when the
president
and others in the administration see
leaders from japan
no the east asian countries have
different
interests than the u.s has with china so
how
will how will you uh
have your asian allies collaborate if
you have different interests
well i think uh just like the u.s
relationships with any country there are
areas of mutual interests there are
areas
where we can communicate work together
on even sometimes have disagreements
whether it is
uh economic cooperation or security in
the region
uh and certainly will i expect that
those conversations should cover a range
of topics
okay on asian american question we just
saw the fact [ __ ] that you
are released but it does not address the
demand from aapi communities
uh for more representation
on leadership levels uh what's more
concerning
uh during yesterday's interview senator
tammy blackwood said she
she she's pushing for this
representation
and the white house uh say to her
quote you have kamala you don't really
need
any other agents in the cabinet and the
dark world say
quote that is really offensive
you wouldn't say we have one male
president
there shouldn't be any white male
members of
covenant why would you say that to
someone from the asian community end
quote
what is your reaction to her statement
well first we've had a range of
conversations with senator duckworth
since that call which happened about a
week ago
including a commitment to naming a high
uh asian-american member of the aapi
community
uh to a position in the white house and
that's something we're
working to do through consultation with
a range of officials and
elected officials as well and that
person will be a commissioned officer
and will be
uh working on both policy and outreach
and as soon as we have a name we will
share that with all of you but a big
part of our effort has also been on
taking
actions to address the rise in
anti-asian violence
and bias and underscoring the commitment
of our entire administration to working
in partnership with the ai
aapi community we announced the
president announced that doj has
launched an agency-wide initiative to
address
anti-asian hate crimes and acts of
violence doj is taking steps to
strengthen hate crimes data reporting on
aapi violence improved law enforcement
training so that local law enforcement
agencies can better identify anti-asian
bias
in the coming weeks the administration
will meet with aapi leaders
to hear their input and how we can play
the most constructive role possible in
the community and the president
raised because he felt it was imperative
to elevate
the continuing threats the hate speech
and the
violence against the asian american
community in his speech he gave during a
prime time address a week ago
go ahead yeah i uh actually a good
follow-up for what chingy just asked so
thank you jen
sure um so as you know we've had a spike
in carjackings
in washington dc and there's been a huge
uproar of course about the carjacking
and killing of a pakistani american
by two teenage girls uh does the
president
plan any outreach to the aapi community
of washington
given given this uproar well the
president and his administration he's
asked members of his team
senior levels of his team to be engaged
in a broad
swath of leaders from the aapi community
from across the country
i can certainly check if there will be
individuals from the dc community as a
part of that outreach
okay and given that there's been this
spike in carjackings here in washington
has the white house put any
guidance to to staff who
of course work in washington many live
in washington
has there been anything on that i i
think we would
certainly defer to local law enforcement
and guidance along those lines i'm not
aware of any additional guidance being
put out
let me just go around to make sure it
gets everybody go in the back yeah well
during his press conference last week
the president was very stern and
expressive
when it came to expressing his opinion
about the so-called voter suppression
laws in georgia
and elsewhere but what tangible action
will the president take
to turn that tide particularly when
you're talking about a federal bill
facing
a uphill climb in the senate well
there's a
number of actions one i wouldn't call it
so-called bias
because we know that in communities
across georgia
there have been polling places that have
been closed those are in predominantly
african-american communities so i think
that is
real bias second i would say that we
don't see these and we certainly know
there's an uphill battle for lots of
legislation but
we are encouraged by the conversations
that are happening
about moving legislation forward to make
voting
more accessible more available to people
across the country the president
believes it should be easier not harder
to vote
and he will look for opportunities to
help push that legislation
forward he also signed a number of
executive orders just a couple of weeks
ago
because he believes that uh you know
this is a central
cause and equity uh issue in his mind
and he wants to take
uh take steps from from the white house
steps any president can take to also
make voting
uh more accessible but we also need to
continue to work with local leaders he
met with stacey abrams when he was in
georgia just a couple
weeks ago a lot of the power and the
activism is going to come from the
grassroots and incredible leaders
like stacey abrams who are ensuring
people have the facts they need um the
information they need to vote and that
they push back against oppressive
uh efforts to to make voting more
difficult
how is the white house engaging the
faith community when it comes to gun
control
uh well many members of the faith
community have been quite outspoken
historically about um about
the threats of gun violence that have
impacted communities across the country
certainly that would come from our
office of public engagement uh who would
lead these efforts to outreach to a
range of communities
i can check with them and see if there's
any specific meetings with the fate with
faith groups
in recent days and lastly is that
yeah is there anything to be read into
sort of the rebranding of the
administration to the bonded harrison
administration
branding when you look on the website
it's you know
it's not it's just biden harris and
that's not been necessarily the norm of
the past is there any message being set
by that or what's meant to be
uh what can be extrapolated i would take
from it that
vice president harris is an important
partner she's the first in the room the
last in the room on most occasions if
she's in town and not traveling around
the country
um it's a reflection of the important
role that she will play moving forward
go ahead and speaking with several
governor's offices that were on the call
with the white house this morning
it's come to our attention that there
were not a lot of questions
or really any questions or pushback on
um
the comments yesterday from both the
president
and dr rolinski you know advising state
and local governments against rolling
back
mass mandates just given the fact that
there were no questions or really any
dialogue at least if we're into our
reporting right now what is the level of
concern from the white house
at the effect 24 hours after the
president
raising his voice on this dr rolinski is
certainly raising her voice on this
i mean are governors uh sort of going
their own way and ignoring you all
i don't think we see it that way jeff
but i would say that
one of the ways we can impact people
across the country is by acknowledging
this is hard we've been at war with this
virus for a long time
and to reiterate as the president did
yesterday as dr wolenski did yesterday
that we continue to
be at war with the virus but the way we
feel we can be most impactful is not
just through words but is through
actions and so
as we have seen um in uptick we've also
taken an accelerating threat i should
say
we've also accelerated our response and
we've moved up
universal shot date for most americans
by two weeks increased
vaccine supply to states doubled the
number of pharmacies getting supplied
more than doubled
open more vaccine mass vaccination
centers we know that the more people who
can get
vaccinated the more accessible it is the
more effective
we are going to be and that's where
we're putting our efforts is there
enough concern
from governors based on the call this
morning do you believe
i was not on the call this morning i
think the president's speaking
not just to governors but to people
across the country to business owners to
local elected officials
there are even in some states where
governors have been pulling back
the restrictions there are local leaders
and local businesses or bigger
businesses
who have kept them in place and it's
important for people it's a tough
message
important people to hear that we're
still uh in a war with this virus and
people need to still be vigilant
in order to return to normal thanks jen
today canada halted delivery of the
astrazeneca
vaccine what does that mean for this
administration's posture towards that
particular
vaccine and the vaccine's prospects of
approval here in the u.s
well approval would of course be through
the fda and they have a rigorous and
thorough process
for doing that so i will leave that to
them to undergo that
that process and i don't have anything
to predict about the approval
likelihood thank you jeff thank you
wanna go one more
sure one more question okay given
on the near term horizon yeah is the
white house considering changing the way
it deploys those vaccines since those
kick in so much quicker than the other
vaccines the johnson and johnson
vaccines
sticking to the same per capita
distribution or is there any thought
about changing the way those are
distributed
well we we think a lot about how to
ensure vaccines are distributed
equitably across the country
um but our message continues to be you
should take any vaccine that is
available to you there are three
approved they're all safe they're all
effective
so we're not changing our approach at
this point thank you everyone thank you
you